ce que je faisais avant de me donner pas
l'occasion de savourer chaque jour
chaque jour est un cadeau parce qu'il
est gagné
plus accueillons notre terrien du samedi
20h ce soir Lorraine bonsoir
alors tous les thés le ice bucket
challenge à inonder les réseaux sociaux
le but récolter des dons pour la
recherche sur la SLA la sclérose
latérale amyotrophique alias la maladie
de Charcot le problème c'est que le
message d'origine c'est perdu en route
aujourd'hui les gens ne voient plus que
le seau d'eau sur la tête et oublie le
but de l'opération qui est d'aider à la
recherche sur la maladie de Charcot
Lorraine vous nous raconterez à 20h ce
qu'est la maladie de Charcot
[Musique]
Lorraine rebondoir
vous êtes né à Paris le 8 août 1962
après le lycée vous faites des études à
l'École Supérieure de Commerce et très
vite vous décrochez des postes à
responsabilité dans des grandes
compagnies multinationales et là vous
travaillez 12 heures par jour et vous
voyagez sans arrêt vous êtes une femme
extrêmement active et même pendant les
vacances vous apprenez à piloter un
avion de tourisme
ote et en plus excellente danseuse de
rock
patiente
alors cette formidable énergie est
entretenue par une hygiène de vie
impeccable une coupe de champagne à Noël
aussi à mon anniversaire et puis un jour
de l'été 2011 vous n'arrivez pas à
ouvrir une pince à linge avec la main
gauche parce que vous êtes gauchère donc
vous le faites avec la main droite
vous vous dites voilà c'est pas grave
quelques jours plus tard un verre vous
glisse des mains vous vous dites c'est
pas grave quelques semaines plus tard
vous faites une chute dans la rue et
vous vous dites ça doit être les talons
ou il va y avoir une bosse sur le
trottoir et puis ces petits symptômes
anodins se multiplient vous avez des
crampes et vous avez des espaces
musculaire petite vibrations sous la
peau et il faudra attendre 6 mois avant
que vous alliez voir un généraliste qui
vous oriente vers un neurologue à
l'hôpital de la Pitié-Salpêtrière et un
mois plus tard le diagnostic tombe et
celle là sclérose latérale amyotrophique
la maladie de Charcot et là vous dites
c'est un seau d'eau glacé qui m'est
tombé sur la tête d'abord j'étais
totalement stupéfaite puisque je passais
d'une situation où je décale quelqu'un
qui me considérait en très bonne santé
et en une seconde j'ai découvert ce que
c'était quatre malades et je ne
connaissais pas du tout cette maladie
après renseignement j'ai découvert
qu'elle était dramatique alors là le
verdict effectivement c'est la triple
peine d'abord vous avez entre trois et
cinq ans d'espérance de vie vous disent
les médecins
deuxième sanction la SLA est une maladie
dégénérative ça veut dire qu'elle ne
s'arrête jamais petit à petit elle
paralyse tous les muscles du corps
d'abord les fonctions motrices et puis
ensuite la déglutition et la respiration
troisièmement le handicap donc la
dépendance il faut toujours quelqu'un
pour s'occuper de vous
là pendant plusieurs semaines c'est
l'abattement total
oui complémenter d'un très grand
désespoir
parce que je suis quelqu'un comme tous
les malades qui aimons avoir une
solution et en fait à ce moment là et
d'ailleurs encore maintenant
nous n'avons pas de solution auquel nous
raccrocher donc ça c'était un moment
très très difficile très difficile et là
vous avez une vision vous faites un rêve
éveillé on peut dire et vous voyez une
équipe qui vous aide dans cette épreuve
assez vite j'ai imaginé que je n'y
arriverai pas toute seule donc j'ai
imaginé que d'autres médecins d'autres
personnes avec des compétences
même différentes de la médecine serait à
mes côtés pour m'aider à confronter la
maladie parce qu'en fait c'est à la fois
faire avec puisqu'elle est là et lui tu
es contre
vous êtes croyante
je le deviens
oui et ça aide alors vous vous dites à
ce moment-là il faut que je reprenne ma
vie en main malgré tout et si ça doit
être court au moins que ce soit beau
dans un premier temps vous la jouer
classe vous snobez la canne vous prenez
un parapluie c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus élégant d'avoir un
parapluie qu'une case
sont les béquilles et bientôt encore le
fauteuil roulant et là vous dépendez des
autres ça vous avez besoin qu'on
s'occupe de vous vous avez besoin
d'auxiliaire de vie évidemment pour
votre toilette pour votre habillement
pour la pour la cuisine les repas vous
faire manger d'une certaine façon
même votre brosse à dents c'est à dire
qu'on vous met le dentifrice sur la
brosse électrique et vous la tenez avec
les deux mains c'est ça tu la tiens en
fait avec mes deux poignées puisque mes
doigts ne plus de force et là ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que vous engagez
dans le financement de la recherche sur
la SLA la business woman que vous êtes
organise un gala caritatif et vous
récoltez 120000 euros ce qui est
beaucoup d'un seul coup vous arrivez à
utiliser ce que vous savez faire ce que
vous êtes pour lutter contre votre
maladie c'est assez beau
en fait j'ai des ressources et puis
cette maladie ne touche pas le cerveau
enfin les capacités intellectuelles si
vous voulez donc j'ai voulu mettre mes
compétences qui étaient en métier des
ressources humaines et surtout de la
communication au profit de la maladie
qui me touche et qui touche un grand
nombre de personnes alors là vous
rencontrez Clémentine Célarié et Thierry
Monfray qui sont en train de monter un
spectacle de danse qui s'appelle la
danse immobile et quelques mois plus
tard vous vous retrouvez sur la scène du
du Festival d'Avignon oui clémentine et
Thierry m'ont parlé de leur projet et ce
spectacle pour moi tout de suite
réveillé
le goût de la danse et c'est comme ça
que je suis rentrée dans le spectacle
avec un rôle et nous avons fait
effectivement le Festival d'Avignon cet
été le spectacle continue toujours les
gens peuvent aller le voir
ils le 13 août dernier donc juste après
Avignon vous découvrez l'ICE bucket
challenge
[Applaudissements]
alors
aux États-Unis 100 millions de dollars
ont été récoltés en un mois et le
problème c'est qu'en traversant
l'Atlantique le ice bucket challenge a
perdu son sens parce que ici les gens
font plutôt ça faut le dire comme une
blague de potage en fait on peut faire
le iceber challenge
en mentionnant que c'est au profit de la
recherche sur la SLA en nommant trois
personnes et faire un don
ou ne pas choisir de ne pas faire le
reste challenge et faire un don alors
vous cette maladie vous a quand même
apporté des choses c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que vous
avez appris par exemple à évacuer le
superficiel effectivement c'est assez le
paradoxe
de cette de l'arrivée de cette maladie
dans ma vie c'est que
ce que je faisais avant de me donner pas
l'occasion de savourer chaque jour
chaque jour est un cadeau parce qu'il
est gagné vous avez découvert la joie
tout simplement de la contemplation
c'est à dire de regarder le monde qui
est beau
regardez quoi enlever de soleil je
regarde lever de soleil je regarde la
couche et de soleil je regarde les
nuages dans la journée
la nature en général et puis j'apprécie
beaucoup les rencontres que je fais les
contacts que j'ai avec des nouvelles
personnes aussi vous avez dit juste je
veux vivre le plus longtemps possible
c'est tout le mal qu'on vous souhaite
Lauren merci beaucoup et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu